foreign
with the writing the poems
it it's crazy to me that that you seem
to strive to not really play a role in
making the music you want the music done
and then well it depends on the project
right yeah so you know historically I
wrote a lot earlier with tool we all
wrote together I would bring a piece
everybody brings something to it same
thing with Puscifer with Billy he wrote
a bunch of stuff he just had a bunch of
stuff written so that was kind of the
process that we just kind of went with
with perfect circle well with the
Puscifer there's a lot more
collaboration going on between Matt and
Karina and I uh tool like I said early
days we were all writing but as you get
older stubborn more successful and the
ego start to swell and all four of us
can't fit our heads in one room you know
one of us has to back out and just let
that fight occur and then wait for the
chips to fall and then go okay
I'll write some poems to that yeah so
you get the music and then and
notoriously the music can take a long
time to get to you and uh and then when
it does get to you you turn around
because you're trying to react to the
music yeah yeah and generally that's
that's how I write I've been
recently I've been working in in logic
finally unlocked
the logic Magic Door where I can come up
with rhythms and Melodies that are just
kind of you know sketched on a napkin
and I'm able to write a lot more music
in that way because I'm not a drummer
I'm not a guitar player I can play
guitar
I can barely tune a guitar and that's
how I used to write it as on a bass
um but I just kind of like because
there's better bass players because
there's better guitar players that's
just going to let them do that but now
that I've unlocked just little uh tool
no pun intended in logic I'm like I have
this new thing now where
um I can't have I can't finish my coffee
unless I write at least a beat or a
melody
in logic and then send that off to Matt
and Karina and Puscifer go here here's
my here's my morning coffee so like at
least three a week
I send them something so I'd like this
folder of like 40
things I've been working on over time
and I'm sending some of those to if it
sounds like it's leaning toward A
Perfect Circle it's leaning toward tool
I'll send them those away but usually
you just get crickets back from those
guys so
like that's a cute riff
stay in your [__] Lane
nice do you like shopping on Amazon I do
and good news is Stevo's butt wipes for
your butthole are available on Amazon
and if you want a real bundle of a deal
you can get Stevo's hot sauce for your
butthole plus Stephen's butthole
destroyer and Stevo's butt wipes for
your butthole it's the butthole bundle
available on Amazon right now
yeah dude